[Music]
was Tristan Thompson really spotted
kissing another woman the Cleveland
Cavaliers player is expecting a baby
girl with khloe kardashian any day now
but on Tuesday multiple reports surfaced
of Tristan allegedly stepping out on
Khloe with other women
the Daily Mail obtained one video of
what appeared to be Tristan making out
with a mystery woman in New York City
well a source tells ET exclusively that
video is not what it looks like
quote the video going around shows
Tristan in a loud Club briefly talking
to a girl nothing more our source adds
quote Tristan was there for roughly an
hour and left with his teammates Chloe
and Tristan are happy and focusing on
the birth of their daughter Chloe has
been relaxing in Cleveland snapchatting
as recently as Tuesday morning on Monday
she captioned this photo kissing Tristan
writing we are ready whenever you are
little mama a source told a teen last
month that despite their busy schedules
Chloe and Tristan do not want a
long-distance relationship adding
they're going to be very hands-on
parents
[Applause]
you